smith's food and drugstore the sponsor
of this segment has been on the front
lines to ensure everyone has access to
the food services and products they need
during this unprecedented pandemic
september is hunger action month and we
have smith chief and we have smith chef
jeff and aubriana martindale from
smith's corporate affairs to tell us
more
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from smith
today is a special day i have a my
special friend aubriana why are you here
today you know september is hunger
action month and that's our favorite
month in september because it's all
about making sure people have access to
fresh food so today we're using
something a little different when it
comes to jeff's recipe so what are we
cooking today so today i'm making just a
really quick beef chili with black beans
but what's special about this recipe
is that i'm using food that's
i guess you could say rescued it's food
that's near it's it's it's expiration uh
produce that's near and what's cool
about smith's is they have these uh
you've probably seen them before these
reduced stickers um that's what they do
to stuff that's getting near its its
date um and it's just a great way to
save money but it's also a great way to
use up that food that may otherwise be
thrown away so it's really kind of cool
that way so at smith we have a social
strategy called zero hunger zero waste
so we do our best to eliminate food
waste across all of our operations to
help and hunger so jeff just talked
about food rescue that's something
you'll see right here this is perfect
produce that may have a few blemishes
but is still nutritious and still human
consumable so we want to make sure that
we're not throwing this away and
sometimes we just need to change our
perspective on how we can use this
produce
one in five children don't know where
their next meal is coming from so if
there's a child who hasn't had an apple
in a week we can easily just skim off
some of this peel and use it in a recipe
like you're doing here right for sure or
just use it all together i mean
you know what a banana that's brown is a
better banana than one that's not you
know what i mean so it's just that that
mentality of the they don't have to look
perfect to be healthy or even delicious
so right
so there's some other things that we can
do at home to savor food one thing that
we can do is meat so it's surprising to
know that expiration dates aren't
regulated right
those dates are just put forth by our
vendors saying that's potentially peak
quality so what do we do when we want to
taste that food yeah so if you've got
some of this reduced meat that you get
from the meat department throw it in
your freezer and it can last for up to
four to six months so
you're using a product that you get for
cheaper and you're not throwing it away
you're saving it it'd be perfectly fine
in your freezer for six months i
actually had a gallon of milk the other
day
that i was using
10 days past its desperation and it was
still
perfectly fine right so those expiration
dates doesn't mean that the food has
gone bad use your senses give it a
little taste test right usually it can
go past those days smells exactly freeze
it on the expiration date you can also
freeze milk on its expiration date and
it can last months longer so thank you
jeff thank you for helping us eliminate
hunger in our communities and you can
always make a difference miss different
smiths by rounding up to the next dollar
at any register and all of those funds
get donated to your local food banks so
look at this chili so this is my chili
we use the the food that was almost
expiring and it looks delightful right
we're gonna dig right into that i also
was able to find some discounted muffin
mix so there you have it thank you guys
so much for watching and thank you for
shopping we will see you all next time
bye-bye
thank you to smith's food and drug for
sponsoring this segment visit them
online at smithfoodanddrug.com for more